[Musique]
je suis plutôt bois plutôt blonde ça
dépend si c'est si mal quand il est brun
j'aime bien quand il est blanc jadart
bon je suis plutôt bonne
jaubert alors je m'en fous des yeux tout
l'air et manquer ce qu'on fait avec ça
on fait rien c'est assez dur si dure si
dur humour beauté bien sûr ça se voit
l'un à la main mais beauté mec rasoir
c'est relou pour coller de l'ensemble
supports possibles et en même temps
l'humour c'est parce qu'on va en premier
on perd vers didot
au bilan ce intelligence intérieur que
l'intelligence ne s'achète pas tralala
intelligence la rançon j'annulais j'ai
toujours malheureusement choisi
l'intelligence ça m'apparaît ici
alema c'est ma silhouette les yeux
tendres sont tous les saints adro igolo
positivement aux énergies gentil gentil
gentil générosité à d'une grande
patience dévotion nombreux et fidèles
fidèles c'est pas possible
levis les bidons sentir la transpiration
et la gueule du loup tout donné tu es
tout ce que j'aime jouer au web et à
james last man aa vieux murs de ford
piot les formes et trop dirty dancing
obligatoirement love actually le remake
de love actually truc le plus romantique
du mae a tracé pourrait parfois un film
d'horreur et après la la land comme ça
me protège
[Rires]
[Musique]